[Music]
Iraq and Afghanistan are very different
Wars
they've been equally ill-advised in my
opinion Iraq what I saw in Iraq was a
civil war straightforward civil war and
I remember a moment in 2007 and you know
three of my soldiers were already dead
about eight had been wounded in a unit
of just 20 soldiers so we were pretty
battered we were pretty beaten up and
there was a moment when we were
retrieving bodies quite frankly because
in the night the two militias would just
kill these teenagers and attack each
other and in the morning the bodies
would be there for us to find and so I
was recovering bodies as we often did
and on the way back from the recovery of
these bodies we were hit with an ID
right and and so I realized not only am
i policing a civil war that only started
because of the American invasion but I'm
being attacked by both sides in the
Civil War because of my presence because
of the American occupation so America's
occupation had unleashed a civil war I
don't think was on purpose but it was an
ill-advised invasion we didn't
understand Iraq or its inner dynamics
it's ethno sectarian meelo we did not
understand that so I think for Iraq what
turned me off was watching the civil war
unfold and America's helplessness to
truly respond Afghanistan I would call
the unwinnable war and again that's my
opinion
but if you look at Soviet record in
Afghanistan or the British record in
Afghanistan it has gone poorly for any
occupier over the course of a several
hundreds of years of history it would
take more soldiers than we are capable
of providing it would take more money
than we can afford and what we've done
instead is we've sort of muddled our way
through an ongoing insurgency with the
Taliban and here's the problem in both
in Iraq and Afghanistan the government's
we put in place the governments that we
you know it's their democratically
elected but if America creates the
conditions for these governments we back
certain parties the governments that
we've put in place are generally
considered illegitimate corrupt only
marginally effective in both Iraq and
Afghanistan so what we have in
Afghanistan is the unwinnable war
seventeen years after the war starts and
the Taliban is stronger today in control
of more provinces today and there is
nothing that 15,000 American soldiers
can do besides die of course they can do
that but there's nothing that fifteen
thousand soldiers American soldiers can
do besides muddle along and keep the
insurgency going
and just keep everything that sort of a
stasis we're not winning and so if we're
not winning then I think that we have to
take a hard look at our interventions in
Iraq and Afghanistan and if we're gonna
take a hard look at Iraq and Afghanistan
we ought to take a very hard look at our
other undeclared wars in Yemen Libya
Pakistan Somalia and everywhere else
that we're currently either bombing or
or you know flying drones over so when
you talk about why we're there I mean
because this is an important question
you know what are we doing if not
winning I wish it was as simple as what
some sort of conspiracy theorists or or
certain pink parties think it's all
about the oil or it's all about the
money and and all of that is a part I
think it's much more complex I think
there are two major pieces you know two
major things the threads that hold us in
these wars number one is that there's a
lot of profits being made in the
military-industrial complex
quite frankly the war selling arms is
one of the last American industries
that's left ok it's one of the last
things the United States does well that
we're still number one at number one at
dealing arms in the world number one at
supporting our military our military
budget is eight or ten times Russia's
okay it's three times China's it's more
than the next nine or so in a row so
that's one threat and the other one is
we've got sunken costs okay it's a
sunken cost dilemma
we've lost all these soldiers we've
spent all this money we're fighting
terrorism okay well that's a tactic it's
a very strange thing to declare war on
we're fighting Islamist extremists we
say in the Middle East when we do that
if we pull out there's a a portion of
the American electorate I would say
probably a majority that would say well
we can't leave because if we leave
they'll be more terrorist attacks on us
but we can't leave we've already spent
7,000 lives and 2.2 trillion dollars and
so I think this sunken cost fallacy
steps in so what do we have now we have
the inertia of a military industrial
complex which makes a lot of money for a
lot of people and keeps a lot of people
employed on one end and then we have the
sunken cost fallacy on the other side
where we say we've committed so much we
can't possibly leave and it's it no
president wants to be the president that
lost the war on terror instead
we're in our third administration now
okay President Bush he just wanted to
leave without losing rock obama totally
different figure he wanted to leave
without losing he didn't want to be the
president that lost the Warrens her and
i would argue that it is very unlikely
that President Trump will be the
president who ends the war on terror so
that means we're looking at potentially
up to seven more years of war with no
end in sight and no one even talking
about final victory anymore and that's
interesting because soldiers will join
the army next year who were born after
9/11 and we need to think on that for a
second and what that says about our
Republic what that says about the nature
of service and the nature of warfare a
perpetual warfare in the American psyche
how do you tell a child how do I tell my
teenager what what piece even looks like
he's never lived it he's never seen it
was born in 2002 I think we have a lot
of there's these are things we're gonna
have to grapple with as a society it's
more than just the military it's more
than just the defense industry or the
politicians we have to grapple with what
it means when a republic okay an
ostensible democracy goes to war and
stays at war for decades
[Music]